to some trending news this afternoon
more theaters are opening their doors
again to moviegoers studios are eager to
finally release some big blockbusters
that have been shelved this whole past
year regal theaters will reopen its
doors tomorrow but the question is
will audiences come back what's been
really encouraging
to hollywood is just how
many tickets have been selling
internationally
people do want to come back to theaters
when they feel it's safe
they will get back that's right king
kong making audiences feel safe is a
priority for theaters
and most are going the extra mile to
make sure customers can actually
see their copic precautions if audiences
show up this summer
the film industry could finally spring
back yeah it's been such a tough year
and sherry all we can think about is
when's james bond coming out
that's my question yeah that's going to
be a big one i think
i think it'd have to be a pretty big
blockbuster to get people back in the
theaters or do you think people are just
going to be ready to go and
munch on popcorn and sit in those big
cushy seats yeah i think a lot of people
just want to go out and do something
probably so they'll take it you can take
the whole family and you've got black
widow coming out soon too
i'm anxious for that one as well a lot
of good movies hopefully when they're
released it'll be
the flood gates will open we will see
what happens we'll